let's read this first story we got from
timcast.com
enforcement of new york city's vaccine
mandate for children 5 to 11 to eat in
public already appearing on social media
the expanded key to the city guidelines
have now impacted families and the city
and tourists coming to experience the
big apple the most notorious video is
this one here where you can see the
thing let me turn the volume down you
can see there's a little boy he's
surrounded by nypd officers who are
demanding his vaccine papers and they
say if you don't have the papers you
can't eat here now
it's it's hard to know to break down
exactly what's happening because it's an
applebee's and they didn't want to give
us all the details
but we do have this
uh let me let me start from the
beginning new uh the rule expanded
monday to require anyone over the age of
12 to show proof of a complete two-dose
vaccination a video circulating on
social media tuesday morning appears to
depict an nypd strategic response group
attempting to eject a family from an
applebee's in queen center the family
which included young children did not
provide proof of vaccination
anyone 5 and up must show a vaccine card
in order to eat here jose perez manager
of the applebee's in the queen center
told timcast we have been attacked by
protesters and our staff is on edge and
the police have been helpful
while perez said he cannot comment on
that incident seen in the video he said
that no kids have protested he added i
am tired of having to answer these
questions people have been calling
nonstop and we have work to do here it's
very busy well
i wonder if it's just journalists
calling but good on the people who are
calling and asking questions now here's
something i think is very important
we have a quote here christina myers a
host at margaritaville resort in times
square said she turned away more than 20
would-be diners by midway by midday
sorry they can eat outside but who is
going to eat outside with five and
six-year-old kids in this weather
foreigners don't understand why we had
to turn them away even people from union
city in new jersey were confused that's
the point i think is most important here
when i saw that video of that little kid
being you know questioned by the police
i lived in union city just on the other
side of the river
no mandates as far as i know right now
so people are coming across into
manhattan confused as to why they're
being ejected from these businesses this
is not just foreigners this mandate
means that people in the greater new
york metro are going to be impacted by
this
and i got to tell you
i see a video of cops asking a child for
their papers and uh none too pleased
with it i don't know
absolutely they should be ashamed of
themselves following orders is not an
excuse illegal does not mean it's moral
ten cops while the city is being plagued
with crime and violence are now going
after a five-year-old because he didn't
get government permission to eat at
applebee's i mean are you freaking
kidding me this is a new level of
deprived politicization
of the police force of the authorities
that are abusing their powers in order
to appease these benevolent little
leaders that are issuing these decrees
that are absolutely totally backwards
and nonsensical and the details here
matter because at first when i saw that
video i was like oh man why are why are
protesters bringing their kids to this
and having them interact with police
officers being traumatized in this way
but but the fact that these people
weren't protesters the fact that they
were just there trying to enjoy their
meal interrupted by police officers
saying give me your paperwork or else is
disgusting and i'm sick and tired to see
this happening to a place that i grew up
in destroyed by bureaucrats and
plutocrats who don't give a damn about
the people sorry i just had to go on a
rant because that makes me mad so i have
i guess the contrarian trait here which
is that i think that it's a positive
thing the police are enforcing this as
opposed to businesses i don't think this
changes until people have a very clear
line of accountability as to who is
actually responsible for these mandates
and what i actually think the way that
the de blasio administration has done
this is really really clever um because
they have made the businesses the bad
guy businesses that have been closed
forcibly closed for a year they're
trying to to make back um an edge
in their businesses and they have been
forcibly roped in to enforce this
mandate so when i see police enforcing
this mandate i think that's the only way
this is going to change because people
see those videos the one we're talking
about right now and they say this is not
acceptable but when it's just a guy at
the applebee's turning you away well
that's not great video and by the way
when when those um businesses are
protested like blm protested a
restaurant that turned away some
customers in the summer those businesses
are trying to stay like in business as
well they're they're unwilling uh sort
of participants in a mandate that is
coming from the government and therefore
should be enforced by the government uh
and and that's how that is how like
democratic change happens is when people
actually know who to hold accountable
that's actually a good point you know
when when when people see videos and
it's like you're trespassing and it's
like the manager everyone's like well
it's a private business
seeing the police do it well now you've
got the potential the potentiality of
the right and the left being like we are
all now mad at the police for doing this
however
i kind of think the left is going to
invert their police position now and
they're going to support the cops for
doing this so it's not really going to
have have an impact
ultimately if if the left and the right
both were like okay we're now angry the
police are doing this i'd be like okay
well you know there you go maybe now the
police will back off and say we're not
gonna enforce this but i don't see that
happening i do see the left just
inverting their position because they're
do they're posting it on twitter so as
far as i'm concerned i just take the
individualist approach if the government
performs what is what was it the the the
ash experiment in the milgram experiment
was that what was called malcolm
milgram and then the ash experiment was
people willing to deny reality if the
majority told them to so if you have
people who are willing to just deny
reality and then enforce edict because
someone told them to the problem is them
i'll give you i'll give you guys a
really simple uh uh
experiment they did that's really
fascinating they put a person in a room
and they said we're gonna do we're doing
a study here we want you to fill out
this application the application
actually was the study they put them in
a room they had them felt the form and
they blow smoke under the door
when it was just one person in the room
they see the smoke they run to the door
they feel it they start yelling there's
smoke there's smoke fire fire
the next the next group they did they
put three people in the room and what
did people do they saw the smoke looked
at the other two people and then just
ignored the smoke so if if you've got
people looking around and seeing no one
taking action it's it solidifies the
problem individuals simply need to step
up and say we won't do it and you'll see
people follow suit i don't think the
left's going to defend this because the
images are stark here and they're very
important i mean we're seeing a child
being intimidated by dozens of police
officers this is not just one police
officer enforcing this the nypd is
bringing out dozens of police officers
men with guns that are going up to
five-year-olds and saying hey give me
your paperwork or you're in trouble
that's that's disgusting and this this
isn't just happening in new york city
this started in italy it's going on in
germany it happened in france there's a
picture going around that is depicting
french police officers interrupting the
matrix movie inside of a theater going
around asking people for their vaccine
mandates for their vaccine passports for
their government permission domestic
passport slip paper to be in a movie
theater to watch a movie i mean imagine
sitting at a movie theater trying to
enjoy a meal and a police officers give
me your paperwork coming over your
shoulder breathing over you with weapons
violent men being like
give me what i want give me compliance
or they're interrupting the movie man
that's the nature of political power and
i think it's important that the nature
of that political power is clear and
open and on a video that people can see
i think frankly not just with regard to
this but with regard to many many issues
the major problem in our institutions
and in our political culture today is a
lack of small d democratic
accountability
and i think there's a reason they
enlisted businesses to do that it
scrambles the lines of accountability
nobody to your point about people you
know being willing not to comply a lot
more people are going to be pissed off
and willing not to comply when they see
five-year-olds being arrested than when
somebody is screaming at the 22 year old
hostess at applebee's by no means i i
totally disagree with both of you
because
with the blue pill normies see video
like that they don't see it the way that
we see it they're gonna look at that
video and they're saying that poor child
has an irresponsible parent that did not
get three shots like i was conned into
getting and now that parent should be
held accountable for not taking care of
their child being a responsible parent
and this is just fine they wouldn't say
conned no no they wouldn't say that yeah
they would be like that kid did the
right thing exactly terrible exactly i
don't think there's a lot of people out
there like that i think there's a
perception that there is a lot of those
people out there but i think that's
carefully curated and manipulated i
think a lot of people are saying hey the
first one didn't work the second one
didn't work now the third one's going to
magically work why how where where's the
data where's the science what's going on
here a lot of people have some very
serious questions that the medical
professionals are not answering in this
country and they can't answer those
questions and that's leading to a lot of
people being like hey why are we giving
up our human rights our rights to even
sit alone at a restaurant our rights to
be alone and watch a movie in peace to
to these bureaucrats that aren't keeping
us safe in exchange for this bargain
that we're making with them because
that's the bargain they promised we're
going to give you safety we're going to
give you security just give us your
human rights i would give us your i will
take your dignity risky freedom over
totalitarian security any day but what's
the end result of this then what abolish
the police everybody in new york gets
mad at cops and says defund and abolish
no i i think this is the end result of
this is when people start to actually
feel the pain of the policies they have
an opportunity this is still a
democratic country they have an
opportunity to change those policies
and i agree with you i think even in new
york city that there are a lot of people
who are let's say not like the folks
around this table um but are still they
see that video and they see like this is
going too far this is a problem i think
there are still a lot of people who just
don't pay attention uh to
how and and um in in what like sort of
mechanism this stuff is being enforced
and again when they're asked by the 22
year old waitress at applebee's they
don't get mad but when they see a
five-year-old child arrested by the
police or harassed by the police
they do and they start to actually think
about whether or not
that law makes sense i mean this is the
lanconian thesis right the best way to
get rid of a bad law is to enforce it
strictly that's a paraphrase he didn't
actually say that but um but the gist of
the speech he gave was exactly that and
he was referencing um
fugitive slave laws right which he was
radically against and he said actually
if these laws are on the books we should
enforce them because that is that is how
people will realize this is a bad idea
if we selectively enforce it or we muddy
the lines of accountability we have no
way of actually changing people's minds
and getting rid of stuff like this so i
i'm glad to see the police enforce this
instead of the waitress at applebee's it
reminds me of that scene from v for
vendetta when the inspector is like
eventually someone will do something
stupid and it shows the little girl
skipping and she's wearing the the guy
fox mask so that the cop shoots her and
then all the locals just walk up with
like pipes and crowbars
when people start seeing five-year-old
children being surrounded by cops and
questions having their papers and i
agree with what you were saying you know
it's gonna it's gonna it's gonna set off
a lot of people probably a lot of moms
i'd imagine and that's that's a huge
powerhouse is what steve bannon was
telling us
women control the political landscape
what did he say the french revolution
didn't happen until the women came out
of their houses and marched and then it
was like uh-oh so when i i think you see
these kids who was i marched like that
before the the bolshevik revolution do
wow see there you go
international international women's day
is a celebration of that's why it was
originally celebrated by communist
countries it's the the women's working
march yeah you see i think little kids
being surrounded by cops you're getting
a lot of women who are going to be upset
about that not only that but people are
being sent off to camps in australia
there's police officers walking up to
individuals being like we need to check
your cup we need to make sure that
there's coffee in there because if
there's not you're in trouble what what
kind of world did you want to be living
in where violent thugs with guns come up
to you and demand for you to show them
your coffee because you're walking down
the street are you kidding me that's not
a world i want to live in that's an
absurd world a world that of course is
carefully put into place by top down
central controllers and this is what
they want this is what they called for
and they're only going to get it if
people consent an echo yes to it and i
think a lot of people had enough that's
my perspective that's how i think it's
going i i think it's important that we
make sure that there are still venues
for people to express that they've had
enough because a lot of not only the
covets um sort of regulations but a lot
of our policy is decided in this country
by unelected bureaucrats and they don't
have any reason to listen to ticked off
parents right um and and so i think i
don't know i tend to think of a lot of
political problems in this way i i
really think that what we need at this
moment and i'm not always i'm a
conservative i'm not always sort of
enthusiastic about um small d democracy
i don't think it's always the
the best um you know sort of answer
there is there is a danger of the
tyranny of the majority but i think in
our particular moment
we're not in danger of the tyranny of
the majority we're in danger of the
tyranny unelected minority essentially
we were talking about this a couple of
years ago tim the uh
a specific study that was done showing
how democracy was a joke and how the
major policies that people wanted were
never passed the policies of special
interest groups were passed showing how
essentially the works of congress is
being done by the people who have the
power who have the money the special
interest essentially all of them uh i
forgot the name of that specific stuff
there was there's a chart it showed that
uh the that public opinion had a
zero percent impact on public policy and
that the opinions of wealthy elites had
a massive impact on public policy that
is what you get when you slow off
political decision-making into
bureaucracies yeah right washington d.c
um and to a lesser extent the states but
primarily in washington dc um
the vast majority of political decisions
are not made by congress right this is
what was so absurd about aoc for example
being mad that west virginia has a
powerful senator um the reality is the
views of brooklyn right are reflected
much more in an elite class of like a
managerial class of bureaucrats and
those people are not responsible to the
majority most of our political decisions
are made either by bureaucrats or by
courts which are properly placed beyond
democratic control but they've gone
beyond what they're supposed to be
ruling on between those two things
there's a smaller and smaller space for
the people to express any kind of
opinion or displeasure with the
direction of policy thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you